si vaccin qu'ovide c'est le nom de ce
nouveau fichier de données et créer pour
les personnes vaccinées
il a pour objectif la mise en oeuvre le
suivi et le pilotage des campagnes de
vaccination qui ont débuté ce dimanche
en france parmi les données collectées
on va retrouver les informations au
personnel des personnes vaccinées et des
éléments sur l'injection comme la date
le lieu
le modèle du vaccin ou encore le
soignant qui s'en est chargé le but est
d'envoyer aux personnes concernées des
informations sur la vaccination est de
pouvoir les contacter je cite en cas
d'apparition de risques nouveaux
on pense par exemple à d'éventuels
effets secondaires
alors qui aura accès à ce fichier
les soignants réalisant la vaccination
les médecins traitants et la caisse
d'assurance maladie
d'autres professionnels de santé
pourront consulter certaines
informations
mais après ceux de nomination c'est à
dire la suppression des noms prénoms
adresse numéro de sécu de téléphone et
adresse mail
objectif permettre d'assurer le suivi de
la couverture vaccinale est de mesurer
l'efficacité de la vaccination
toute personne pourra apparemment faire
valoir son droit à l'effacement de ses
données personnelles
à condition qu cela entre dans l'un des
cas de figure listés par le règlement
européen de la protection des données et
la campagne de m